As fun as it is to watch a great movie,
there’s no guarantee that you’ll walk out
of the theater feeling good yourself. Here are a
few fantastic flicks where the last few minutes
are so monumentally depressing that they’re almost
guaranteed to wring a few tears from the audience.
If you only saw the last three minutes of End of
Watch, you might think this cop drama was ending
on a happy note. The final scene features two
buddies having a laugh over a crazy story on what
looks like a pretty good day. Unfortunately,
context is everything. In actuality,
the camaraderie between Officers Brian Taylor
and Mike Zavala is an incredibly bittersweet
flashback scene, one that jumps back to a moment
before Zavala was gunned down by gangsters.
Taylor and Zavala are super cops. In
fact, they're such good cops that they
try to take down the Sinaloa Cartel…
only that doesn't pan out too well.
After disrupting the cartel's business, the
officers are ambushed by heavily armed thugs,
and despite their bravery, Taylor is
gravely injured, and Zavala is murdered.
After learning about his partner's death, Taylor
is absolutely shattered. Zavala was his best
friend in the world, and at the funeral, Taylor
is so grief-stricken that he can only muster
four powerful words that make all those happy
moments heartbreaking: “He was my brother.”
Despite their god-like superpowers,
the Avengers are a sad bunch of people,
and the most tragic might just be Steve
Rogers, a man out of time. In Captain America:
The First Avenger, the star-spangled
superhero decides to sacrifice his life,
crashing a Hydra plane into the Arctic ice. In
those final moments before taking the plunge,
Cap promises to take his new love Peggy Carter
dancing as soon as he returns. Obviously,
neither expect Steve to make it back
home, but, well, you’ve seen the movies.
“I understood that reference.”
When Cap finally returns, he learns that he’s
been asleep for nearly seven decades. It's a
gut punch of a moment, and the look of shock and
sadness on Cap's face is heartbreaking. Yeah,
he survived the suicide mission,
but the world he knew is gone,
and he’s been separated from the woman
he loves for most of a century. When Fury
finally asks if Cap is going to be okay,
all his pain is summed up in one sentence:
"Yeah, I just — I had a date."
War movies aren't really known for their upbeat
endings, but when it comes to pure tearjerking
power, nothing goes after your heartstrings like
1989’s Glory. This Civil War flick tells the story
of the 54th Massachusetts Infantry, which was the
first African-American regiment to fight for the
Union army. The regiment was led by Colonel Robert
Shaw, played in the film by Matthew Broderick, and
after overcoming all the racism you’d expect from
the 1860s, Shaw and the 54th wind up leading
the charge in the film's climactic battle.
Unfortunately, that battle doesn’t go their way.
After being surrounded by Confederate soldiers,
Shaw charges the enemy, hoping to inspire his
men, and he's quickly gunned down. Enraged,
Private Silas Trip, a role that earned
Denzel Washington an Academy Award,
picks up the flag and charges after the
colonel, only to be shot down seconds later.
Their sacrifice inspires the rest of the 54th to
rush out of the ravine and continue their charge,
but despite their bravery, the heroic soldiers are
no match for cannonballs, and all the characters
we've come to love — played by the likes of Morgan
Freeman, Cary Elwes, and Andre Braugher — are
blown to oblivion. If that wasn't sad enough,
the movie ends with Shaw's and Trip's bodies
being buried side by side in a mass grave.
Gone Baby Gone isn’t exactly a feel-good film
to begin with, and the ending is appropriately
downbeat. Based on the novel by Dennis Lehane,
this thriller follows two Boston detectives
— Patrick Kenzie and Angie Gennaro — who are
hired to find a little girl named Amanda. At
first, they believe the kid was murdered by
a local drug dealer, but as they dig deeper into
the case, they discover a surprising conspiracy.
As it turns out, Amanda's concerned uncle
kidnapped her from her abusive, addict mother
with the help of several high-ranking cops, but
Patrick isn't a big believer in moral ambiguity,
and brings brings the conspiracy down
and has the little girl sent back home.
“You may not regret it when
you get home… but you will.
Sure enough, it doesn’t take long for regret to
set in when Patrick goes to visit Amanda. He sees
that her mom is just as awful as ever and realizes
he might've damned Amanda to a life of poverty,
neglect, and mistreatment. In the final few
moments, he volunteers to babysit Amanda and
sits beside her, watching the traumatized,
lonely kid as she stares at the television.
It might seem weird to say this about a
movie where a gorilla fights a helicopter,
but Rise of the Planet of the Apes has more
than its fair share of emotional moments.
Nothing can top the finale, when Caesar,
ably played by mo-cap master Andy Serkis,
says goodbye to his human friend, Will Rodman.
Their relationship is the emotional crux of the
story. Caesar has known Will his entire life,
and the biologist is basically his adoptive
dad. In fact, Will is the guy who gave Caesar
is above-average intelligence. But after Will
is forced to put Caesar in a primate sanctuary,
the chimpanzee decides it's time for a revolution.
After sparking a full-blown primate rebellion
and a battle on the Golden Gate Bridge,
Caesar and his army disappear into a redwood
forest. But before vanishing into the trees,
Caesar is confronted by Will, who
begs the chimp to come back home.
That's when Caesar pulls his foster
father close and whispers into his ear.
"Caesar is home."
With those three powerful words, Caesar and
Will realize nothing will ever be the same.
Tom Hanks movies generally leave audiences feeling
pretty good, but Road to Perdition is a bloody
exception to that cheerful rule. This gangster
flick finds Hanks playing Michael Sullivan Sr.,
a mob enforcer out for revenge while trying to
make sure his surviving son, Michael Jr, doesn't
wind up dead too. That's easier said than done
when you're being hunted by a psychopathic hitman.
For a moment, it seems like everything
might be okay. Then, Michael's violent
past catches up with him when he's ambushed by the
assassin. After taking two bullets to the back,
Michael lies dying as the psychopathic
hitman assembles an old-timey camera
and begins taking photos of his bloody
victim. Michael Jr. shows up with a gun
to interrupt the hitman’s sick hobby, but
unlike his dad, the boy isn't a killer.
Fortunately, the distraction gives his father
enough time to gun down the assassin before
shuffling off this mortal coil. What really
seals a deal and cues the sobbing, though,
is Michael Jr.'s final lines, answering the
question of whether his father was a good man:
"I always give the same answer. I
just tell them he was my father."
Directed by Martin Scorsese, Shutter Island is a
frightening film noir that finds Leonardo DiCaprio
as Teddy Daniels, a detective who's investigating
a disappearance on an Alcatraz-style mental
hospital. But as Teddy and his partner dig deeper
into the case, Teddy makes a horrible discovery:
he isn't really Teddy. In reality, he's
Andrew Laeddis, a World War II vet who killed
his mentally ill wife after she murdered their
kids. His partner is actually his psychologist,
and the whole investigation is an elaborate
role-playing game meant to bring Andrew back
to reality. And if the game doesn't work,
then poor Andrew has to get lobotomized.
After this shocking twist, it seems that
Andrew reverts back to his Teddy persona,
forcing his doctors to perform the lobotomy. But
before he's taken away to his mind-numbing fate,
Teddy looks over at Chuck
and asks a haunting question:
"Which would be worse? To live as a
monster, or to die as a good man?"
It’s a simple line, but it conveys the
crushing sadness of Andrew’s story. The
experiment worked. Andrew knows exactly who
he is and what he’s done, It’s his guilt that
leads him to accept his grisly fate.
Arnold Schwarzenegger movies aren't
generally considered tearjerkers, but the ending
of Terminator 2: Judgment Day has caused so many
sobs from macho movie fans that it’s basically
the action movie equivalent of The Notebook.
“You think I’m unemotional! I can be emotional! I
cried like a child at the end of Terminator 2...”
Sent from the future to protect teenage John
Connor, the T-800 starts out this sci-fi flick
as an ice cold killer robot. As he spends
time with the future resistance leader,
however, the T-800 becomes the teen's best
friend and father figure growing increasingly
lovable as he battle with a shapeshifting
android. He's picking up slang words,
developing human emotions, and learning
you can't just go around killing people.
He also realizes that if humanity is going
to survive, then all Terminators need to
be destroyed. After defeating the T-1000,
Arnold realizes that if he doesn't destroy
the advanced AI inside his own head, that tech
will eventually give rise to the robot rebellion
that will doom mankind. So despite John's
pleas for him to stay, the T-800 slowly lowers
himself into a pit of molten steel. He gives
a thumbs up before disintegrating completely,
letting John know everything is going to be okay.
Despite that reassurance, poor John is in tears,
and so is everybody watching the saddest
ending in Schwarzenegger's career.
One last Ram Jam
With movies like Requiem for
a Dream in his filmography, it's safe to say that
Darren Aronofsky loves a truly depressing ending,
but of all the films he's ever directed, none
have caused as much sobbing as The Wrestler. This
gritty and grim drama follows the story of Randy
"The Ram" Robinson, a professional wrestler who's
far from his in-ring glory days. This dude has
a lived a hard life and made some bad decisions,
and now he's all alone. His daughter
doesn't want anything to do with him,
his romantic life isn't working out, and the world
outside the ring is nothing but pain and misery.
Lonely and depressed, Randy gets
back into the wrestling game,
where at least the fans respect and adore
him. But stepping back into the ring comes
at a high price. Randy has a bad heart and knows
that another match might be his last. However,
when he hears the cheers of the crowd, the
wrestler climbs up on the turnbuckle to perform
his signature move…even as his heart starts to
fail him. When he leaps down onto his opponent,
we know it's the last time he'll
ever do the legendary "Ram Jam,”
but it's all worth for it Randy, because
he's living and dying for the only family
he's ever known, the fans… who now have to watch
their hero die in the ring in front of them.
Man on Fire may not have been a favorite of
critics, but Denzel Washington's performance
as alcoholic bodyguard John Creasy was one of the
most moving of his career. After years of booze
and bullets, Creasy gets a shot at redemption as
a bodyguard for Pita, played by Dakota Fanning.
When a powerful crime syndicate captures Pita,
Creasy buys pretty much every gun in Mexico and
goes on a murder spree, eventually
capturing the kidnapper's brother.
Dying from a gunshot wound, Creasy trades
himself for the safety of his charge. But
before handing himself over, he reunites
with Pita for just a few seconds. When he
tells her goodbye, it's a moment that will
make even the toughest action fan weep.
"Where are you going?"
"I'm goin' home, too."
While the boxing drama Million Dollar
Baby may at times feel as inspirational as Rocky,
Rocky Balboa never ended a movie quite like this.
Hilary Swank plays Maggie Fitzgerald, a backwoods
waitress hoping to make her name as a boxer,
and director Clint Eastwood plays
grizzled trainer Frankie Dunn.
Dunn is reluctant to teach a woman at
first, especially one as old as Maggie,
but eventually her persistence wins
him over. Maggie proves her worth,
KOing her way to a championship fight — and
that's when the movie takes a hard left turn.
Maggie is paralyzed from the waist down when her
opponent illegally punches her after the bell.
Our hero falls hard from the punch, smashing her
neck against a footstool. Maggie loses her leg,
and she begs her trainer to end her
suffering. Dunn refuses at first,
but agrees after Maggie tries and fails to
commit suicide. Before Dunn administers the
lethal injection, he tells Maggie
the meaning of her Irish nickname.
'Mo Cuishle' means 'my darling, my blood.'
Even steely-eyed Eastwood can't keep
the tears back here, and you know if
even Dirty Harry is getting weepy, there's no
way you're going to be able to hold it back.
"Niagara Falls, Frankie Angel."
After the tragic death
of conservationist Timothy Treadwell at the jaws
of a brown bear, director Werner Herzog assembled
Treadwell's footage and created Grizzly Man --
one of the most moving documentaries of all time.
Grizzly Man follows Treadwell as he journeys into
the Alaskan wilderness, interacts with animals,
and shares his unique view about man's place in
nature. While Treadwell's behavior is sometimes
questionable, it's hard not to admire his
passion. With the help of Herzog's guiding hand,
we grow attached to Treadwell as Grizzly
Man heads for its inevitable tragic ending.
While we go into Grizzly Man knowing Treadwell's
fate, it's upsetting to finally say goodbye to
such a unique soul. In the film's final moments,
we watch for the last time as Treadwell wanders
into the woods, accompanied by two fuzzy
friends and a mournful country song that
feels like it was written just for him.
While Wes Anderson directs comedies,
there's always a deep sense of melancholy
underlying his work. That's especially true
for The Grand Budapest Hotel. Set in the fictional
European country of Zubrowka, the film's narrative
is nestled inside multiple timelines, with
the bulk of it set during the 1930s. Our hero
Zero Moustafa played by both Tony Revolori and F.
Murray Abraham, works as a lobby boy at the Grand
Budapest Hotel under the guidance of flamboyant
concierge M. Gustave, played by Ralph Fiennes.
The plot involves a dead heiress, a missing
painting, and a family of greedy goons,
but the drama revolves around the dark shadow
hanging over this dreamworld. In the 1930s, the
hotel is an impossibly charming world of pastel
colors. As the story continues, both Zubrowka
and the Grand Budapest are overrun by enemy forces
— quasi-Nazis followed by quasi-Soviets. As the
totalitarian horrors of the 20th century creep in,
M. Gustave's civilized world starts to fade away.
Guests stop coming and eventually the building is
torn down. M. Gustave is killed during the war,
communism washes over Zubrowka, and Zero is left
alone with nothing but his memories of better
days. The film ends with the nostalgic
author saying over the closing frame,
"It was an enchanting old ruin, but
I never managed to see it again."
On its cold, gray surface, The Blackcoat's
Daughter is a movie about a girl who's
demonically possessed. But under the
slow-building dread and eerie music,
there's a tragic story about a helpless child
afraid of being alone. Played at first by
Kiernan Shipka, and later by Emma Roberts, Kat
is a boarding school student with some serious
abandonment issues. When her parents are late to
pick her up for the semester break, Kat freaks
out. It doesn't help matters any when she has an
unsettling dream about her parents' untimely fate.
Terrified her parents are dead and that she'll
be all alone in the world, Kat literally makes
a deal with the devil, allowing herself to be
possessed in exchange for companionship. She's
so afraid of losing the spirit's company,
she beheads three people at its urging.
When a priest exorcises the demon from Kat,
she's so scared of being alone that she begs
the beast to stay. Unfortunately, her pleas
are no match for holy water. Years later,
an older Kat murders two new victims and brings
their heads back to the school, hoping her
sacrifice will summon the demon. When she realizes
the evil spirit has left the school behind,
the movie ends with Kat sobbing and screaming
into the wintry void. She realizes now that
she's truly by herself. Nobody will ever come to
pick her up, and even the devil doesn't want her.
Directed by Damien Chazelle, La La
Land follows two star-crossed lovers:
Emma Stone as aspiring actress Mia and jazz
devotee Sebastian played by Ryan Gosling.
Mia and Sebastian enjoy the happiness and
heartache all long-term relationships face.
Eventually, because of their conflicting
ambitions, they go their separate ways.
Five years later, Mia is a movie star and
Sebastian runs a thriving nightclub. One
night they lock eyes across a room, and we're
treated to an elaborate dream sequence. It's
the kind of ending we expect to see — the guy and
girl end up with one another and live happily ever
after — but the dream soon comes to an end with
Mia and Sebastian once again going their own ways.
It's a heartbreaking reminder that the choices
we make always leave the door open for regret.
Before Tony Stark made his Iron Man suit and
before Christian Bale donned the Bat-cowl,
there was Hugh Jackman as Wolverine. Jackman
played Logan to perfection, to the point where it
seems almost impossible that any actor could ever
replace him in the role. He defined Wolverine for
well over a decade, appearing in every X-Men movie
up until his blood-soaked swan song, 2017's Logan.
Set in the near-distant future, Logan
follows a dying Wolverine as he uses
the last of his strength to protect
the young Laura who Logan eventually
learns is actually his daughter. A shady
scientist wants Laura for nefarious purposes,
and he has the vicious cybernetic Reavers
under his command. At first Logan is such
a broken man that he wants nothing to do with
Laura, and only the aging Professor X convinces
him to do the right thing. Unfortunately
Professor X doesn't survive the journey,
but Logan continues to help Laura all the
same. When Laura and other mutant children
try to escape into Canada, Wolverine makes his
final stand in the woods to protect their escape.
But even after fighting off all the Reavers, Logan
still must face a clone made to be a stronger,
younger version of himself. With the
help of Laura and her young allies,
the clone is killed, but Logan's wounds
are too much for him. Thankfully,
after a brutal life full of hard decisions,
Logan enjoys a moment of fatherly love before
shuffling off this mortal coil. In the film's
final scene, a tearful Laura gives Logan the
eulogy he deserves, quoting Alan Ladd's final
monologue from the classic western Shane.
"There's no living with the killing. There’s no going back.
Right or wrong, it’s a brand. A brand that sticks."
After ending her speech, Laura tips the
cross on his grave over on its side,
marking the Wolverine's final
resting place with an X.
While the past few years have given
us plenty of amazing superhero movies,
Logan was the first superhero film to truly make
audiences weep for such an iconic character.
Since Thanos' first MCU appearance in 2012,
Marvel fans couldn't wait for the big purple
baddie to throw down with the Avengers.
The MCU filmmakers only gave us brief,
teasing glimpses of the Mad Titan; first a
little bit in the initial Avengers movie,
then a lot more in Guardians of the Galaxy,
and later in Avengers: Age of Ultron. Finally,
six years after Avengers, Thanos finally arrived
with his Infinity Gauntlet, and Earth's mightiest
heroes were completely overmatched. It looked
like Thor was going to save the day when he
slammed Stormbreaker into the Mad Titan's chest,
but as the God of Thunder quickly learned —
"You should've gone for the head." End on the snap
And just like that, with a snap of his fingers,
Thanos wiped out half the population of the
universe, including the majority of our beloved
heroes. Along with most of the Avengers turning
to dust, almost all the Guardians fell victim
to Thanos' purge. Rocket was there to watch
Teenage Groot fade away, and to hear his final
"I Am Groot." Adding to the sorrow of many fans,
Guardians of the Galaxy's writer and
director James Gunn would eventually
reveal that Groot's last "I am Groot"
translated into the word, "Dad."
For many fans, Peter Parker's death was
the most painful to watch. Even though
he just fought the toughest villain in the MCU,
Peter's still just a kid, afraid of fading away.
Infinity War might have the darkest ending of any
major blockbuster ever. There's no moral victory;
no feel good speech. For the first time, the
Avengers have truly lost, and it all ends
with Thanos admiring his handiwork, smiling
as the sun rises on a "grateful universe.